[Music]
in our new original we cover something
that should be of interest to many of
you now that the pandemic related movie
slowdown has already eased in 2022 many
exciting Blockbusters are waiting to be
released in the coming year well it's
time to give you an overview we hope you
enjoy our original video for the most
anticipated Blockbusters of 2023
in February Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania will be running in theaters
Not only is the film The Third in the
Ant-Man line it's also the very first
film from Phase 5 of the MCU Scott Lang
the main character made his last
appearance together with his girlfriend
hope Van Dyne in the victory against
Thanos at the end of Avengers end game
an important element in the new film
will be Scott's daughter Cassie she has
built a satellite that can transmit
messages into the quantum realm later on
the whole family finds itself inside the
tiny world and meets Kang the Conqueror
who makes his debut in the MCU films as
a new super villain the cast includes
Paul Rudd as Ant-Man eventually Lily is
wasp and Jonathan Majors is Kang who was
previously teased in the Loki series the
director is again Peyton Reed who has
already directed the two previous movies
on February 17th the time will finally
come for you to watch Ant-Man 3 in
theaters
the third part of the Creed movie series
will be released on March 3rd 2023 we
will once again see actor Michael B
Jordan the leading role as well as for
the first time in his film career as a
director in terms of plot the movie
picks up where the previous one ended in
the second part main character Adonis
defeated his rival Victor Drago and can
now be at peace back then Victor's
father Yvonne killed the Donna's father
Apollo these events were already shown
in Rocky IV in 1985. so things turn out
well for the main character for the time
being there's even a happy ending for
Sylvester Stallone's Rocky so what else
could be told in the third part
according to an official synopsis Adonis
Creed is at the peak of his career and
his family life is also expanding
however the focus of the plot is on
another matter after many years Adonis
reunites with his childhood friend
Damian who was then considered a boxing
Prodigy and has spent several years in
prison in the meantime having nothing to
lose he wants to fight his former friend
Adonis in the ring to prove it to
everyone so again things get very
personal in Creed 3. in addition to
Michael B Jordan we see Jonathan Majors
as Damian Tessa Thompson as Bianca
Taylor and Wood Harris as Tony Evers Jr
who is the boxing coach of Apollo and
Rocky at the time we are excited for
more news before release and look
forward to watching the film in movie
theaters on March 3rd 2023
in mid-march we will see the release of
Shazam Fury of the Gods the sequel to
2019's Shazam which was received
positively by viewers overall after we
were already introduced to the
protagonist Billy Batson in his life as
a teenager in Philadelphia in the first
part the story of him and his superhero
through ego Shazam will soon be told
further now his siblings also have magic
powers and are able to actively support
their brother Billy in his fight against
evil forces however before they can
compete against the anger Daughters of
Atlas they must first learn how to use
their new powers responsibly so far not
much else is revealed we do know however
that director David F Sandberg is back
and that the script was again written by
Henry Gayden on the side of the cast
Zachary Levi gets to shine Anew with
Shazam Asher Angel plays Billy Batson
once again and we of course also get to
see his siblings in an unchanged cast
the three daughters of Atlas who are
Furious about the sibling's magical
powers are embodied by the audience star
Helen Mirren Kill Bill vol 1 actress
Lucy Liu and Rachel Ziegler known from
West Side Story Shazam Fury of the Gods
will be be released on March 17 2023
in March after a flop in the year 2000
the second attempt to bring the pen and
paper role-playing game Dungeons and
Dragons to the big screen will be made
an adaptation is considered rather
difficult since those responsible have
an enormous role-playing game as their
model which is very individual depending
on the game and doesn't tell a
consistent story as in a comic or a book
however this also gives the directors
and screenwriters Jonathan Goldstein and
John Francis Daly a great deal of
artistic Freedom as filming has already
been concluded since the summer of 2021
there is already a first trailer showing
the stars in action for the first time
the cast includes Chris Pine as The Bard
Michelle Rodriguez is a barbarian Hugh
Grant is the villain and reggae Jean
page is a paladin the storyline revolves
around a gang of Thieves with The Bard
as their leader who embark on an Epic
Quest as director Goldstein already
announced in 2020. the movie will be
quite funny and humorous while it's not
a pure comedy it's an action fantasy
film with comedic elements in any case
it will be exciting to see what the
responsible parties have adapted from
the role-playing game the trailer
already off offers us some initial
insights including the popular dragons
as fearsome opponents Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves will be out
in theaters on March 31st 2023
John Wick chapter 4 cannot be missing in
our preview of course as we already know
from synopsis this time the protagonist
is going to deal with the high table at
the end of the previous movie we see how
Wick is betrayed by his Confidant
Winston and almost dies thus John Wick's
story should carry on more or less
uninterrupted only this time his
opponents are even more powerful and
thus way more dangerous in the first
trailer you can already take a look at
the new footage in addition to John Wick
the cast includes hiroyuki Sonata as
shimatsu Lawrence Fishburne is the
Bowery King Ian McShane is Winston Bill
Skarsgard is Marquis and Donnie Yen is
Kane Akira actress Rina sawayama will
probably also play a big role however it
is not clear yet who exactly her
character is and what her relationship
with John Wick will be by the way this
time the script was not written by Derek
colstad but by Army of the Dead author
Shea Hatton and predator's author
Michael Finch we are eager to see how
the story of Baba Yaga continues and
look forward to the theatrical release
on March 24 2023
a few weeks ago the first trailer for
the upcoming Super Mario Brothers movie
was released surprisingly the first look
of the main characters was very well
received only a few visual details on
Mario and partly the dubbing were
somewhat criticized nevertheless the
trailer demonstrated that the movie
adaptation of the world's most famous
plumber which has been in production
since 2018 is on the right track and
ready for a cinema release joining the
team are Chris Pratt as Mario Anya
Taylor joy as Princess Peach Charlie day
is Luigi and Jack Black as Bowser was
already considered a secret favorite
based on his appearance in the trailer
also joining the film are Keegan Michael
key is Toad Fred Armisen is Cranky Kong
as well as Seth Rogen as Donkey Kong
there's also a pleasant surprise to look
forward to voice actor Charles martinet
who has been known for the iconic voice
of Mario for years will be heard in one
or more cameos in terms of plot the
movie will revolve around the well-known
narrative Mario and Luigi must join
forces to free Princess Peach from the
clutches of Bowser an interesting aspect
will be the introduction of the Kong
family into the story which could mean
that Donkey Kong Island might even be
added to the what aesthetic the director
of Super Mario Brothers is Aaron Horvath
who is still rather inexperienced in the
film business and Batman the Braven the
Bold Creator Michael jelinek minions the
rise of crew writer Matthew Fogle penned
the screenplay the Super Mario Brothers
movie will be released in theaters on
April 7th 2023
the third and final installment of the
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise can be
expected in May with James Gunn now in
charge as CEO of the new DC Studios this
will certainly be his last MCU movie for
a long time some time has now passed
since the second part strictly speaking
it will be more than six years by the
time the new movie is released as a
result the predecessor takes place
before infinity Wars in a completely
different time than the mcu's phase 4
which is now coming to an end not much
is known about the exact plot yet we
only know that the film will be set
after the end of the month's holiday
special and that it will be the final
film featuring The Guardians we are
familiar with this at least suggests the
movie will end with a bang and surely
some of our favorite characters will be
heroically kicking the bucket once again
the script was written by guardian's
Creator James Gunn who also be directing
the film in addition to the returning
cast of Dave Bautista's draft Chris
Pratt as Star-Lord Zoe zaldana as Gamora
Vin Diesel is Groot and Bradley Cooper
as Rocket there will also be a number of
exciting newcomers for instance Will
Poulter will make his debut as Adam
Warlock while The Suicide Squad star
Daniella melchior has also been cast in
an as yet unknown role along with Maria
bakalova as the voice of Cosmo the space
dog on May 5th 2023 it will finally be
time to see many of the old and new
stars of Guardians of the Galaxy 3. in
their roles for the very last time
fans of action-packed car races and
stunts that regularly defy the laws of
physics can look forward to Fast and
Furious 10 in mid-may the 10th
installment is very likely to be the
penultimate film in the main series
before it is finally brought to a close
with Fast and Furious 11 in the distant
future so far the cast is impressive all
the great actors of recent years are
sure to be involved including Vin Diesel
as Dom Michelle Rodriguez's Letty Tyrese
Gibson is Roman ludicrous is tedge Sung
Kang as Han and many more there's no
lack of newcomers either for example we
will get to see Jason Momoa as the new
villain and The Suicide Squad actress
Daniela melchior in a still undisclosed
role there is one person who will stay
out of the movies however and that's
Dwayne Johnson apart from the fact that
Johnson has plenty to do anyway the
dispute with Vin Diesel continues to
weigh heavily on him and so in the
future they will be focusing more on the
Hobbes and Shaw spin-off little is known
about the plot of Fast and Furious 10.
AKA fast X however that should certainly
change soon as the film is scheduled to
hit theaters on May 19th 2023
the oscar-winning animation hits
Spider-Man into the spider-verse will
get its long-awaited sequel next summer
as has been known for some time main
characters Miles Morales will receive
even more active support than in the
first movie just recently for example it
became known that Spidey actor Tom
Holland will make an appearance in
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
joining the cast as well is Yuri
lowenthal who dubbed Spider-Man in the
PlayStation game likewise it has been
confirmed that nope actor Daniel Kalua
will play the role of spider Punk who is
comparatively new in the comic book
Universe in addition to shamake Moore
who will dub Morales returning
characters include Oscar Isaac as
Spider-Man 2099 and Haley Steinfeld as
Spider Gwen the new villain will be
Jonathan own AKA spot voiced by The
Grand Budapest Hotel actor Jason
Schwartzman who is sure to give the many
Spider-Man and Spider women a run for
their money we are excited to see what
director joaquim dos Santos will come up
with and look forward to Spider-Man
across the spider-verse which will be
released on June 2nd 2023
one film that promises an action-packed
movie summer is Transformers rise of the
beasts the franchise's seventh feature
is the responsible party's big hope of
getting the franchise back on track and
finally putting an end to the many years
of poor box office performance a first
step in this direction was made with
bumblebee in 2018 as Not only was the
film well received but it also managed
to gain a foothold alongside the main
series Transformers rise of the beasts
it's supposed to be set in the 1990s and
follow Hasbro's Beast Wars storyline
basically there are three opposing sides
the Autobots the terracons and the
maximals the main antagonists in the
upcoming movie will be the Terracon
although their exact involvement in the
story is not yet clear a definite
highlight is the return of Optimus Prime
who is a fan favorite and the figurehead
of the movie series he will once again
be voiced by Peter Cullen which has been
met with a very positive response among
fans on The Human Side we get to see
Anthony Ramos as ex-military Noah and
Dominique Fishback as scientist Elena on
the maximal side there are also some
familiar names such as Ron Perlman as
Optimus primal and and Michelle yo is
Air Racer this time Transformers rise of
the beasts is not directed by Michael
Bay but by Creed 2 director Stephen
cable Jr we are excited for the first
trailer the seventh part of the
Transformers franchise was released on
June 9th 2023
hardly any other DC production has
caused as much of a commotion as the
flash the reason for this is lead actor
Ezra Miller who's been involved in one
scandal after the other and may even
have to serve a prison sentence soon on
account of a burglary after the 30 year
old Miller has expressed remorse in
recent weeks Warner Brothers has decided
to back him and to release the film in
theaters provided that nothing else
comes up in terms of plot main character
Barry Allen AKA The Flash travels back
in time to prevent his mother's murder
which in turn affects his own timeline
and causes major chaos Michael Keaton's
appearance is Batman which has long been
confirmed will no doubt be one of the
highlights of the upcoming film time
will tell with the movie and its events
mean for the dceu moving forward either
way we should be eager to find out
whether post-production will go smoothly
from here on the flash is expected to
hit theaters on June 23 2023
the world's most famous movie
archaeologist will soon be making his
comeback after 15 years Harrison Ford
now 80 will use his Whip and put on his
hat for the very last time as Indiana
Jones we can therefore look forward to a
grand finale to the movie series The
Plot revolves around Indy going back in
time to be exact to New York in the year
1969. there he has to deal with Nazis
once again which presumably have their
hands in the iconic moon landing program
mads Mickelson will play the main
antagonist of the movie a character
named valer we are pretty intrigued for
the film's release on June 30th 2023
foreign
any other film series is as renowned for
its well done action and daring stunts
as Mission Impossible next year marks
the release of the now seventh
installment which is being produced back
to back with part eight of course Tom
Cruise will once again Star as Ethan
Hunt and he'll be joined by Simon Pegg
as Benji Rebecca Ferguson as ilsa and
Vanessa Kirby as Alana to name but a few
Henry cerny's Eugene kittridge is also
back in its role after many years as for
the plot hardly any information is
available yet at least there's already
been a first trailer and plenty of
reports about the stunts which are more
or less characteristic at the film
series the main attraction is a
motorcycle stunt and a dizzying height
which is said to be Tom Cruise's most
dangerous stunt to date the director of
the film is again a familiar face namely
Christopher McCrory he has a long
history of working with Tom Cruise and
for example also directs the most
successful film in the series to date
Mission Impossible Fallout we are thus
looking forward to tried and tested
quality for the theatrical release of
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
1. on July 14 2023 foreign
in the second half of 2023 another movie
from Phase 5 of the MCU awaits we're
talking about the Marvels which unites
Carol Danvers Monica Rambo and Kamala
Khan the crossover movie is set after
the events of One Division and Ms Marvel
there we were already able to observe
Kamala and Carol in a post-credits scene
as they confusingly swap places when
using their superpowers as screenwriter
Bishop K Ali already confirmed in an
interview with deadline the origin of
the mysterious connection between Carol
Kamala and Monica will be revealed in
the film The emphasis will also be on
the more human problems of the three
superheroids Brie Larson's character
will become much more complex and Monica
will also have to find her peace because
she believes Carol abandoned her mother
back then we can also look forward to an
appearance by Samuel L Jackson as Nick
Fury moreover it is considered certain
that the upcoming MCU series secret
Invasion will have some sort of relation
to the Marvels Candyman director Nia
DeCosta who by the way is the youngest
female director ever in the MCU will be
in charge of directing the film The
theatrical release of the Marvels is set
for July July 28 2023
denieville news sequel to 2021's Dune
were released at the end of 2023 after
the previous movie was released under
the premise that it was released in
theaters and on HBO Max at once this
time will almost certainly be a pure
theatrical release returning cast
members include Timothy chalamet as main
character Paula trades Zendaya's Chaney
Rebecca Ferguson as lady Jessica and
Stellan skarsgarders Baron Harkin big
new additions to the cast include
Florence Pugh as Princess erieland and
Christopher Walken who will play the
Fearsome Emperor Chatham IV the movie
will continue to tell Paul's story
focusing on his new life among the
Freeman in addition he must avenge his
family and take on Baron Harkin it while
still reconciling his love for Chaney
the movie is based on Frank Herbert's
novel series dude however it is hard to
tell how much of the book's storyline
director denieville new will incorporate
into the finished film Dune part 2 were
released in cinemas on November 3rd
2023.
just a few days before the end of 2023
we can finally enjoy Aquaman in the lost
kingdom the predecessor set the bar very
high and is regarded as DC's most
successful film with box office takings
of almost 1.15 billion US Dollars the
plot naturally revolves around Arthur
Curry who reluctantly took over as the
king of Atlantis in the first part and
as a result triggered a massive
spectacle exactly where things are
headed from there is not entirely clear
but it will probably become more and
more gloomy as director James Watt has
confirmed several times in the past in
addition to Jason Momoa as Aquaman and
Amber Heard as Mara Yaya Abdul Mateen II
will again embody the villain Black
Manta the latter is still out for
revenge against Aquaman and will try
everything in his power to make the
superheroes life a living hell a first
look at Aquaman's new suit can already
be found on momoa's Instagram account
where by the way it can also be seen
together with Ben Affleck who after many
years makes a comeback as Bruce Wayne
AKA Batman it promises to be exciting to
find out whether the film lives up to
its high expectations Aquaman in the
lost kingdom were released in cinemas on
December 25th 2023
that was our original for the movie
Blockbusters we are most looking forward
to in 2023 are you excited about the
2023 movie year and if so which movie is
already your big highlight feel free to
let us know in the comments if you want
to be regularly updated in the movies
mentioned and many more we suggest you
check out our weekly news format in
which we sum up the most important
Hollywood news for you every week thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]